welcome back to subnautica say hi ed
Gary hole today very very very exciting
because I've been playing offline
alright I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I don't care I've been building base
look at that look at that got another
one of those did I show this isn't this
cool like I got like the the moonbase
thing oh wait oh god it's flooded it's
supposed to do that don't worry
let me just root why is it flooded what
is happening it's definitely not oh it
was this glitch wasn't it okay
this is not why we're here because I can
finally build finally the Cyclops I
don't know what the cyclic does but it
sounds cool and I'm very very very very
excited to build Cyclops let's flip in
do this I literally just went to like
North East in case you're wondering what
I did I went there and I just scanned
the bottom of the ocean with my
submarine for like 15 minutes and then I
had enough here we go wow it's huge
holy moly small e mighty really lonely
but I'm one I think I know what I'm
doing well
splish-splash in my I'm not gonna say it
do-do-do-do-do-do don't go away dude
it's so big it's so change how do aunt
quiet Taylor quiet my board underneath
yes
that's cool
they compute there is dubstep alright
what's back here nothing Oh ladder Oh
what do we get here upgrades so what can
I can i I don't know what the upgrades
are huh if I extinguisher powers it has
three power cells I close this for no
reason decoy loading - oh I can make
decoys okay and what is that I don't
know can you actually
oh okay I like it where do its Swedish
colors yo y'all believe y'all below IKEA
sub okay here we go engine is offline
yeah power up engine yeah yeah yeah
what next ahead slow emergency speed I
will go with this rig for silent running
okay this is the camera how in the world
I don't have torpedoes how do I control
it's going it's going
hey Taylor oh now I get a radio message
are you kidding me hey you're not so big
now are you you fight oh wait hit
something can we go deeper how deep can
you go with this 500 meters okay we all
live what does that mean excessive noise
that's what my wife says when I scream
to loud am i right gamers when I record
too much gaming and right gamers you all
know what alright is this where I go I
can dock a vehicle on top of this what
no no all right we got to do that we got
to do that this thing is so cool what
does this Cyclops engine efficiency
module
I need benzene decoy tube upgrade
we're on the king of the sea with this
thing we started off with nothing but a
cyclops liquid is now gamers look at us
now do they even have a garden fish I
have a garden oh wait this is not what I
came for
sorry I built another one of these cuz I
thought no vehicle wait I left it
outside that night where is it there you
are
seamos on I do that seemeth is so easy
to fly with though yes I said fly
Dockett wham and of a ducky
hello okay okay okay all right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we'd be docking we'd be
talking Big Al's closest nice okay now
captain cajoled berg commander of ikea
ship we'll figure out how to go
vertically that's all I got so far
there must be a way if it can go 500
meters deep move down see ah yes I've
been using shift this whole time 500
meters here we go gamers okay aye
what is what is happening we're taking
hold damage what did we hit what did I
hey stop this is brand-new the ship has
sailed
alright we need to investigate I need to
do this game alright what happened what
happened to my baby IKEA bird IKEA sub
what happened to you where's your damage
where you hurt my queen my queen
let me hear legit what happened my god
maybe you heal from the inside you know
what I mean it's like a lot dude I have
storage in the ship oh my god this is
what it's like to feel the rich this is
what it's like gamers you just realize
you have all these stuff stop it
it says there's a big error but I'm sure
it's fine really this is not hit
anything else I'll be all right
excessive noise yeah yeah yeah alright
it's slow and steady slow and steady
what the hell did I just what is what
she's giving me anxiety okay so far
we're okay you haven't taken any damage
we're just like blinking inch none
okay spooky sounds perfectly normal
alright so we're down here this is 200
meters isn't it yeah this is where I
found all the materials for cyclists huh
I keep forgetting I have a tail I think
that's the problem you better not touch
my baby [ __ ] stop ooh okay we detected
something all right wait to take
something else maybe this is like a
mating call I want to go as deep as
possible yeah there's a lot of warnings
what is that sound abandon ship abandon
ship oh this is bad
ah freak there's fire in water or you
can't away this is brand new
oh we're gonna go down we're gonna go
down this is bad
abandon ship
get me this no I go down with my boat I
go down with my boat are you kidding me
are you kidding me sad sailor noises I'm
back here destroyed IKEA sub are you
kidding me okay gamers I'm back
IKEA sub 2 is here she's here she's
beautiful I don't dare to go out again
thanks thanks game I don't ever want
that to happen again
what am I supposed to do then I just get
a distress signal as well I'm so
confused maybe I need to build a decoy
so if I head out with this
maybe that's ESU I was literally about
to build one I'm like I can't be
bothered
creature decoy all I need it's like
painting I don't have titanium that's
why now remember it's so easy to get
that I'll just go and get some alright
so my Saab there she is my queen I call
that a marriage yeah yeah I ride the
super fat UFO I almost call it whatever
it's called submarine I thought it would
be a total freaking badass I didn't
think I would just like get the suck
right away alright there's some Taipei I
parked it perfectly like I always did I
always found like a billion of them here
a billion yes a billion what I say a
billion but I just hit myself with my
submarine that's freaking badass gamers
stop alright let's head back really
quick actually let me show you something
cool watch this yeah that was cool right
I know you want to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell notification I
know where's my entrance okay I have a
back interest now look at that we've
glass and stuff and then I can sit and
have fun yes we do have fun I spent all
my titanium building at the base
thinking I never used my titanium
and it literally bit deleting my
aesthetic thing if I had a decoy I'd be
fine
all right so decoy titanium and wiring
kit of course I don't remember how to
build anything in this game because it's
all so conveniently there there's no
point in remembering it oh that's six
excellent no one's gonna mess with me in
my IKEA sub no one stays his rifle I
didn't show this it basically can like
shock maybe I should have used that
against that yeah this time I'm gonna
defend IKEA sub two as if my life made
the flip and depend a depend on it it
Kia sub so glorious so beautiful I love
you you are my child yes my child and my
lover at the same time if it's a
submarine of course only submarine yes
yeah I can only load one once at a time
are you kidding me I'm closing these
here we go
we're really quiet now let's not alert
Anil Olivia tie Anton all right deep we
go let's see what lies beyond I felt
like a total Star Trek moment you know
what the card says that at the end of
the episode and Jim's locked on VP hard
oh I didn't realize
come on can because in him it's like
they don't want to leave what do we have
there what does that mean what this that
none neither Scott deploy deploy decoy
he's attacking me I can't move
I lost the decoy launch equipment you
sneaking IKEA bird two cannot go down
I think the decoy worked I don't know
why he doesn't like me I'm such a good
person you know yeah I go for the decoy
you dumb schmuck efface your face looks
smoky like a schmuck I'm going down and
you can't stop me
IKEA sub for life yeah [ __ ] right let's
talk here another decoy we need to plant
another decoy we got a small leakage
that's fine that's normal in submarines
that's normal
yeah repair repair that like that yeah
we're good
I cannot repair this prawn suit yeah
what is happening alright let's can we
repair it yeah
she's like new yeah the old scum put a
dent in me but not good enough
Hey not good enough hey I need more of
the prawn suit I know that for a fact
thing fact I mundo as we say in Sweden
all the time prawn suit grappling arm
yes
[Music]
hey lien stuff dude oh I know because I
did it I need the actual prawn suit you
schmuck what's the point of leaving this
many of them in silent mode it's fine
oh my god there's so many of them it's
just not hit the honk it's all I got it
okay he's right there oh my god do not
hurt me eh
Oh Oh
can you go please yeah go you dumb
schmuck I bet you don't even have oh oh
he's coming back that's fine
do you not have anything better to do
smooth sailin away smooth sailing no way
oh god I don't think that's good I think
this is bad
decoy
maximum speed mother Flicka there's
another one just let me go oh dude
that's a freakin fire where's the fire
extinguisher no fire in my submarine I
just need to close the doors it's all I
can do we need to ascend as quick as
possible
what guess that we're going down another
one I don't have anymore no not like
this
Oh God then I just stumble into every
goddamn creature in the planet okay
gamers I've been returned on this
episode for the third time this time I I
got the excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me
I got the crown suit I made sure I got
it but I'm too scared of going back
there I'm not going back there so I
realized I can't actually enter the ship
I'm sure oh god there's crabs everywhere
excuse me excuse me can I use this on
you
little little crab little little crab
I don't think so little Rita crab shoot
begone tot let's go because I'm sure
there's gonna be a modification table in
it what did I flip and dip in
finger-licking titties switch and say
anyone else alright floodlight oh that's
cool see I swear I've been missing like
the obvious stuff can I use this here oh
I see
oh I see convenient I didn't even know I
had to do this what a strange fate
I guess it's so you can't go here right
away I just didn't see it I don't have
fire extinguisher I don't think I have
it at least I'm pretty sure I can just
run through we're inside the ship gamers
it's a journey to the underworld
I give me all your alien technology and
stuff oh I can cut it do I have it on me
I don't think you have it on me guess we
have to go back anyway see the game
likes to do that
you think you're good but no you have to
go back and get that one thing maybe the
balls you have to do to play this game
in real life you know what I mean cuz I
don't have those kind of balls I see
that in that quit game I quit life cool
I'm glad it works so well oh my god if
you're on fire just drink some water
gamers Bing badda Bing badda Bing Bing
bong I cut doors down or not long
bing bada bing bada bing Bombo I make
door go pee pee poo yeah don't touch it
ooh oh wow
two batteries that was definitely worth
it data terminal
we have the black box oh my god oh my
god there's so many pipes I am scared
no one likes pipes this much no one I
guarantee it all right all right what do
we got online then whoa whoa dude
there's nothing in here who looted this
place what the tragedy what happened
here dark plague is device oh there's
the prom suit there it is found it spray
spray spray did it it did it there spray
spray spray did it that it's be your
thing yeah yeah yeah mine my mine you
will be mine yeah all right yeah all
right all right living quarters but
everyone dead here nutrient blood spray
spray spray spray spray fire ow fan
spray spray spray keep composter mine
dude they got beds in this plate I can
finally sleep gamers single bit more
like I'm alone bed this is this is so
sad bed swivel chair finally slave okay
hemisphere much favored Clarke and eat
nice damn finally something that's not
fish I will set it I was something to
like find a girl or something you know
there's got to be some reward other than
nutrition bars right I guess I should be
satisfied and we did to find the prawns
suit I think I explored it oh we just
got to find our way back my submarine
better be there Betsy Betsy the beasts
are back oh there are any other
entrances maybe how did I not see this
the first time I'm so dumb excuse me
excuse me excuse me
goodbye you fly now
they fly now they fly now whoa
look at me look at me look at me go yeah
Oh guys I thought we I thought we went
through this oh oh I'm out of battery
excuse me one second excuse me one
second
excuse me one second oh I'm not gonna
die from a halflife copy something tells
me I should just come back here later
when I my inventory isn't full but also
I'm going now
yes a sprayer spray spray spray a
sprayer
oh no I just want a modification table
that's all I want like that's why I'm
here
oh there's something down there I didn't
see that Hey okay I didn't see this okay
all right we go deep and I don't have
the passcode what was the point thing oh
I need actually need a passcode so I'm
sure we're gonna come back here in the
future then it's probably too early you
guys ready for an epic dive Geronimo on
my titty toes yeah
where is he hey you am i beautiful my
bad bear let's get that Frick out of
here did we find a modification table no
we did not
am I pissed about it absolutely yes and
we're ducking in baby perfect yeah oh
wow this place is that's really gone
downhill since I left you're okay you're
okay all right we come back back with
new riches but more importantly more in
motivation thank you
oh my god yes yes yes yes yes excuse me
get out of here
yeah yeah I'm swivel swivel a server
Lynn it doesn't really swivel but I
still prefer it thank you guys for
watching another episode of to
subnautica a most interior smash like
you know the drill
thank you for watching Hado you know
what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course
pixal aims is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
Brazilian players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score
it's safe to say it's the most popular
game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it
build with
[Music]